[Music]
second at a major he was supposed to win
as cloud9 sets the push up oh
always happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
second to the greatest team in the world
reign and guardian left two on four and
you're absolutely right moses there's
nothing left to fight for cardi with a
mac 10. he chases down one but it's
16-12 and astralis
[Music]
nico is undeniably one of the most
talented pros to ever touch cs go two
versus one the world's best player up
against it to stay in the game they'll
go for the fake defuse by nico not
taking the bait can he finish this off
yes he can we're going to write the time
but despite nico's incredible
performances
so far his career has been defined by a
string of falling just short of ultimate
glory you learn the most from the losses
but what's also very important
you will learn from the game that you
win as well but now with the team built
to help him succeed the narrative might
finally change
nico might finally
get his coronation
[Music]
[Music]
going into the 2018 boston major nikola
nico kovach had reached the pinnacle of
the cs world individually he'd never
performed better kerrigan dies in the
last rounds so too in this one
and he's got accuracy
he was on a team chock full of
phenomenal players 2018 phase was the
definition of a super team you look at
this roster and you have three of the
five players were in the conversation
for the best player in the world at some
point olofmeister definitely being the
best player in the world in in 2015 a
guardian when he was in his peak form
also in conversation and nico has always
been around especially since he joined
phase and had some actually good results
with the team played on the big stage
and with nearly six years of pro play
behind him nico was due for the big one
but instead boston turned out to be one
of the most shocking upsets in esports
history guardian waste
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
this happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
so if one of csgo's greatest talents
surrounded by players of equally
monstrous caliber still couldn't win the
major what sort of future did nico
envision for himself going forward
nico has always been an ambitious player
the bosnian serbian pro skill eventually
landed him a spot on mousesports an
offer nico initially refused but once he
became part of the team nico gave mouse
his absolute best gonna be torn away
from them very very quickly by
scientists oh my god nico get three four
oh my lungs i don't believe it shocks
then that's just to find one more the
molly isn't going to touch him and what
on earth has just happened is deagle is
on fire and sharks is going to walk into
it as well nico how does he not get that
kill he has to secure that it does do
enough damage that nico's easily able to
pick it up for nico what oh this guy is
absolutely insane this is characteristic
of nico yeah not only picking up the
deagle in the pistol round so he's still
finding a shot or two three
that's the difference and now they know
that the man is behind yellow as well
twist will fight back but nico's still
alive he's still kicking and he finds
another one
four headshots for nico and the pistol
absolutely unreal unfortunately with igl
duties eventually falling to nico he
found himself overwhelmed and unhappy
and the team's results reflected that
with painful clarity nothing just seems
to be going right for nico and i think
now we're starting to see him kind of
like buckle under all the pressure
having to be the star player at points
having to be the in-game leader having
to call the tactics for the team by
february 2017 mao's nico was no more his
next stop was faze i'm really thankful
to mouse force without them i could not
be where i am at the moment because they
gave me a great opportunity but you
can't be the best player if you don't
have the best team in the world
faze was niko's opportunity to have the
teammates he always wanted the best of
the best the team did really well at
several high profile events with nico
nabbing an mvp award for his outstanding
performance shortly after joining very
careful devices on three they saw the
door shut did they hear the first shots
go through nico sprays in and takes down
devices the result thanks sipping for
the assist but do they can figure that
out do they realize that there's gonna
be two in this position he's got it
lined up he's waiting
on it oh that's still on it nico saves
them and they'll get the defuse they
might be best to stay inside away from
him because he's got glaive down nico
follows it up with a two kill make it a
third it's device in the mix and just as
quick as that it's another round for
phase they go 11-3 up as we head into
round 15 a very impressive ct side he
has to be the savior this round lines up
a couple there's two cracks that's what
we wanted to see and the third nico
saves the round for phase but when it
came to majors unfortunately winning
just wasn't in the cards for faze and
it's a long way home for the faze team
that has to be highest expectation and
worst outcome that i've seen in recent
memory as a major the org decided to up
the ante even more citing players each
and every one of whom was a superstar in
their own right and the results were
outstanding nico was playing the best
counter-strike of his life earning yet
another mvp award at esl one new york
and landing near the top of hltv's 2017
top 20 players list the arsenal toward
the firebox and hope of a kill all in in
one position and guardian makes it just
nicer to find the flash
and nikko fittingly gets the last kill
his face dominate new york in 2017 in
the barclays center all the way through
this tournament now they know where the
remaining players are coming from and it
is inevitable it is over zip nick's down
to five hp and it's not gonna be enough
16-7 win faze have done it they are your
e-league champions four versus two doing
more damage leaving oscar with a ump
he's got to pick up a rifle surely going
past the connector area this is the end
of the line for mouse sports phase after
a massive best of three
shut down the dreams desires of mouse
sports and take the championship sadly
despite all the build up and the hype
the boston major was a huge flop for
faze but the team kept on fighting
astralis are running out players options
and time it's exist and guardian to do
it it's faze plan suddenly goes down
it's just three to five but stink oh
there's the timing on the flank he's got
to pinch it in there
he's out of ammo they know it until they
get on the defuse
he's just barely done it as he oh my god
it's so close
get away with it all through 2018 nika
was still playing out of his mind adding
more mvp honors to his name but when the
time came for another major faze was
steamrolled by astralis marine and
guardian left two on four and you're
absolutely right moses there's nothing
left to fight for cardi with the mag 10.
he chases down one but it's 16-12 and
astralis make another semi-final here at
the major nico was still the third best
player in the world but clearly
something on his team wasn't working
like it should have been the org decided
the problem lay with their igl kerrigan
and replaced him going into 2019. this
did seem inevitable from like the point
where they decided that like oh nico is
just gonna igl now sometimes maybe who
can tell no one knows
um i feel like when you reach that point
within a team then it's obvious that uh
your igl's days are numbered
unfortunately kerrigan's team leading
duties did not fall to the new addition
instead nico once again became the
reluctant igl and both faze and himself
suffered the consequences five on three
now it's up the guardian i think we
might be done here they've got to tap
out there's nothing left as one player
remains and there it is it's 2-0 navi
booked himself a place in the semi-final
in convincing fashion as well and faze
an underwhelming one as they will crash
out in the quarter-finals expected so
much more here map they've got another
flashbang as well once they find out
where he is surely it's impossible a mac
10 for neo versus three can he get
around the corner he can't do it
renegades take it they survive and they
eliminate faith clan from the major nico
was still putting up results and
collecting mvp awards at events faze did
win but his individual results slipped
somewhat in 2019 nico was named hltv's
11th best player which was still
incredible by anyone else's standards
but for the bosnian superstar it meant
he was losing his touch bringing on
coltzera did produce a few bright spots
for the team and another mvp for nico
despite csgo's shift to an online era
but faze still relied on nico to do the
shot calling that combined with
continuous roster shuffles within the
team slowly but surely eroded whatever
momentum they had speaking
of which we will have the b rush coming
in it's not going to look too good two
of them burn straight away stannis thor
with the orc nade and three kills will
ensue never rush b boys nico had some
tough decisions to make and rumors began
to swirl around what his next move might
be one thing was for certain though nico
was ready to move on
[Music]
joining g2 allowed nico to finally ditch
igling duties that had plagued him since
kerrigan's departure from faze and as a
proverbial cherry on top nico was now
also playing on the same team as his
cousin nemanja hunter kovach we
understand each other we are helping
each other and i'm really really happy
he always kept working so hard that he
could achieve that dream that we are one
day now in the same thing nico's overall
performance in 2020 split between the
two teams saw him return to the top of
the list of cs go's best at number four
even though g2's showings were spotty he
swaps over to the ump drops down into
the vents nico knows this look at this
angle he peeks
goodness nico he's crawling forward but
he doesn't realize yet oh my god it's
down to two zip backs denied as g2
arrived topping group three
now there is a huge stack going on on
this bomb site so it won't be easy
unless you get more entries and dexter
he's going to do just that hunter on his
own he spins and he gets it oh my god
after a string of solid third place
finishes and what at last looked like
some stability within the team g2 we're
now facing a new challenge the return of
lands yeah i'm just also happy to be
back on land even though
it's not really the same thing like it
was before but still happy to be next to
the boys and to play together and to
fight together the shift back to offline
tournaments was a huge deal but g2's
results seemed to have fallen victim to
the jitters and were once again all over
the place gets one looking for a second
he's been amazing in this game that's a
second could this be fifth place for
some pies he's only gone and done it the
hope was that by the time cs goes first
major in two years pgl stockholm rolled
around g2 would have it figured out the
pressure is there but we are just here
to fight and whatever happens happens
but i just want to see my team fighting
and giving everything for each other and
so far
it's been uh it's been going good the
eyes of the world were on navi and the
unofficial goat simple but nico was in a
very similar position he was a player of
absolutely inhuman caliber
who was yet to win his major and no
matter what happened stockholm was
shaping up to be a showdown of historic
proportions
and there it is huge opening steals the
awp and now he can hold it oh this is
beautiful
nico is such a god at this game gonna
fall back from the flashbang and they're
setting it up another kill he's doing
everything he truly is the eternal mvp
of this game there's another oh he's
getting the headshot on tessa's as well
he's just won the round on his ears
wielded manifested it into reality
refreshing strush they've got to be left
wondering what is going on a quarter
kill oh
can they line up yep nico mowing them
down triple making a quad going for the
ace gets shut down
only gonna be the one left though and
canadian is not gonna get it done nexa
holds the line hunter turning the corner
no one spotted yabby just yet needs to
be a trade jax doesn't react in time
it's nico left in a 1v1 he knows exactly
where zyphen is and there it is
four kills for nico g2 didn't quite have
the flawless run that navi had dropping
a map to heroic in the semi-finals but
as terrifying as simple squad looked
nico and his team were ready to take
them on in the grand finals running
light on time the warband comes through
calls the bluff
on it he's defusing
he's still defusing knocked off that'll
do
nico saves the day in the last second
the grand final he's the one pulling g2
through but a 1v2 the bomb is ticking
and that's the end of that
16 to 11.
times it to perfection
and simple sitting no no
an absolute disaster
that was it that was it again
[Applause]
[Music]
the miss deagle shot will likely linger
on nico's and the cs go community's mind
for some time i don't know how it
managed to close out i got big time on
the 15 12.
i had a guy in the back and uh
let's see the sucks that it had to
finish this raid but the pgl major was
so clearly simples to win it was almost
inevitable that something like this
would happen
i've cursed them
i have cursed them
navi may have bested g2 in stockholm but
second place at a major is nothing to
scoff at i'm really proud of the boys
and
i think after a couple of days when we
look back i think we'll be happy i
simple have
just won the major and i am still on
zero
i'm confident that at some point in my
career i will be able to lift a major
trophy and
congrats to him he deserved it even more
than i did i think so he played that out
of his mind as for nico himself he was
officially named 2021's third best
player and continues delivering
performances that blow most pros playing
today out of the water and here comes
the attack rops just a quick peek and
falls away jack's missed his chance but
there's the push there's the star factor
nico getting aggressive taking matters
into his own hands and g2 cleaning
things up at a still looking strong on
inferno following their pgl major loss
g2 made a few roster changes most
notably bringing on monasie a young aunt
prodigy who's already being called
simple 2.0 on catwalk finds the timing
eight seconds if you can drop the bomb
it'd be everything but it travels into
the site one on two from odyssey now
it's sacrificial gives this position
away he wants bonuses
oh the shepherd staff takes down the
goat and he takes simple out of the
round to give it to g2 the team is still
getting used to playing together but
they've got plenty of time to find their
rhythm before the next major in may
everything comes back to nico doesn't it
like yeah even him with like hang on a
moment look at this look at this oh nico
flashed in double triple he's gonna
knock out the ram play you cannot get
past him but ramp he's the king of it
until then we can all take a moment to
appreciate nico for who he is
a huge personality nice can you show
them your strength man you're so
strong a passionate player the hg will
almost kill him but not quite and he
takes the round and ace to win the
second one on the board for g to what a
chord and a man dedicated to continuous
growth within cs go no matter how bad
the growing pains may get
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
[Music]
you